En los Institutos Nacionales de Salud
en Washington DC
está la Biblioteca Nacional de Medicina,
que tiene 25 millones de artículos,
el cerebro de las ciencias de la vida y la investigación biomédica.
Podemos usar palabras clave para buscar esa base de datos
y, al hacerlo,
descubrimos casi un millón de artículos sobre el embarazo,
pero mucho menos sobre leche materna y lactancia.
Al buscar el número de artículos que investigan la leche materna,
vemos que sabemos mucho más sobre café, vino y tomates.
(Risas)
Sabemos más del doble sobre la disfunción eréctil.
No digo que no deberíamos saber sobre esas cosas...
Soy científica, creo que deberíamos saber sobre todo.
Pero que sepamos mucho menos
(Risas)
sobre la lactancia materna,
el primer fluido que un mamífero joven está adaptado para consumir,
debería enojarnos.
A nivel mundial, 9 de cada 10 mujeres tiene al menos un hijo en la vida.
Es decir, nacen cerca de 130 millones de bebés cada año.
Estas madres y bebés merecen nuestra mejor ciencia.
Estudios recientes han demostrado que la leche no solo desarrolla el cuerpo,
sino que alimenta el comportamiento y modela el neurodesarrollo.
En 2015, se descubrió
que la mezcla de leche materna y saliva del bebé
- sobre todo, la saliva del bebé -
produce una reacción química que genera peróxido de hidrógeno
capaz de matar el estafilococo y la salmonella.
Y de los seres humanos y otras especies de mamíferos,
estamos empezando a entender que la receta biológica de la leche
puede ser diferente si se produce para hijos o hijas.
Cuando buscamos leche de donante en la unidad de cuidados intensivos neonatales,
o fórmula en el estante de la tienda,
es casi todo lo mismo.
No pensamos que los hijos y las hijas pueden crecer a diferentes ritmos,
o de diferentes maneras,
y que la leche puede ser parte de eso.
Las madres han recibido el mensaje
Y la gran mayoría de las madres quieren amamantar,
pero muchas no alcanzan sus metas de lactancia materna.
No es su fracaso;
es nuestro.
Situaciones cada vez más frecuentes como obesidad, trastornos endocrinos,
cesáreas y nacimientos prematuros
pueden perturbar la biología de la lactancia.
Y muchas mujeres no tienen apoyo clínico bien informado.
Hace 25 años,
la Organización Mundial de la Salud y UNICEF establecieron criterios
para considerar los hospitales como favorables a los bebés,
pues proporcionan el nivel óptimo de apoyo para el vínculo madre-hijo
y para la nutrición infantil.
Hoy, solo 1 de cada 5 bebés en EE. UU.
nace en un hospital favorable al bebé.
Este es un problema,
porque las madres pueden enfrentar muchos problemas
en los minutos, horas, días y semanas de lactancia.
Pueden tener dificultades con la posición de lactancia,
con el dolor,
con la bajada de la leche,
y con las percepciones de producción de la leche.
Estas madres se merecen personal clínico bien informado
que entienda estos procesos.
Las madres me llamarán cuando atraviesen estas dificultades,
llorando con voces temblorosas.
"No funciona.
Se supone que naturalmente debería poder hacerlo.
¿Por qué no funciona?"
Y solo porque algo sea evolutivamente ancestral
no significa que sea fácil, ni que seamos instantáneamente buenos en ello.
¿Saben qué otra cosa es evolutivamente ancestral?
(Risas)
El sexo.
Y nadie espera que empecemos siendo buenos en ello.
(Risas)
Los clínicos brindan mejor cuidado equitativo y de calidad
si tienen educación continua
sobre cómo apoyar mejor la lactancia materna.
Y para tener esa educación continua,
debemos anclarla a la investigación de vanguardia
tanto en ciencias de la vida como en ciencias sociales,
porque tenemos que reconocer
que muy a menudo
los traumas históricos y los sesgos implícitos
se interponen entre una madre primeriza y su médico.
El cuerpo es político.
Si nuestro apoyo a la lactancia materna no es intersectorial,
no es aceptable.
Las madres que deben regresar al trabajo,
porque países como EE.UU. no proporcionan licencia por maternidad remunerada,
quizá tengan que volver a trabajar unos días después de dar a luz.
¿Cómo optimizamos la salud materno infantil
instruyendo a las mamás sobre la leche materna
sin darles el apoyo institucional
que facilite el vínculo madre-hijo
para apoyar la lactancia materna?
La respuesta es: no podemos.
Les hablo a Uds., legisladores,
y a los votantes que los eligen.
Les hablo a Uds., empleadores y gremios de negociación colectiva,
trabajadores y accionistas.
Todos tenemos un interés en la salud pública de nuestra comunidad,
y todos desempeñamos un papel para lograrlo.
La leche materna es una parte para mejorar la salud humana.
En la UCIN, cuando nacen los bebés prematuros o enfermos o heridos,
la leche o los componentes bioactivos de la leche pueden ser vitales.
En ambientes o ecologías,
o comunidades en alto riesgo de enfermedades infecciosas,
la leche materna puede ser increíblemente protectora.
En emergencias como tormentas y terremotos,
cuando hay cortes de electricidad,
cuando no hay agua potable disponible,
la leche materna puede mantener a los bebés alimentados e hidratados.
Y en el contexto de crisis humanitarias,
como las madres sirias que huyen de las zonas de guerra,
las gotas más pequeñas amortiguan en los bebés los mayores desafíos mundiales.
Pero entender la leche materna no es solo dar mensajes a las madres
y a los responsables políticos.
Es también entender qué es lo importante en la leche materna
para ofrecer mejores fórmulas
a las mamás que no pueden o no amamantan por alguna razón.
Todos podemos hacer un mejor trabajo
de apoyar la diversidad de las mamás que crían a sus bebés
en una diversidad de maneras.
Mientras las mujeres en el mundo luchan
para lograr igualdad política, social y económica,
debemos reimaginar la maternidad
no como aspecto central, nuclear de la condición de mujer,
sino como una de múltiples facetas que en potencia hacen geniales a las mujeres.
Ya es hora.
(Aplausos)